[Musik]
die krone hat es kosten ab jetzt drei
euro an eine teststation lauterbach wird
für umsichtige legalisierung von
cannabis und ex formel 1 boss bernie
ecclestone schockiert mit seinem
statement dass er sich für putin eine
kugel anfangen würde und damit herzlich
willkommen meine damen und herren bei
für den nach acht meine gäste heute
abend oft haben wir hier bei vielen
nachdem wir ihn gesprochen und ja und
auch mal über ihn aufgeregt umso schöner
dass er die einladung angenommen hat und
heute abend da ist cdu-politiker und
frühere gesundheitsministerin sparen er
sagt die ampel hat nach wenigen monaten
schon einen wackelkontakt ich bin sehr
gespannt auf die begründung auch mit von
der partie kolumnist harald martenstein
sein thema heute abend die panik
fraktion hält an kroner bevormundung
fest gebt uns endlich die
entscheidungsfreiheit zurück auch
wrestlerin jessica arbeit beschäftigt
die korona panini je dramatischer appell
wir bürger sind am ende fdp-politiker
und bundestagsabgeordneter christoph
meyer r raschen öfter bei uns die
stammzuschauer werden ihn kennt er
forderte raus aus den schulden rein in
die handlungsfähigkeit ab 2023 muss die
schuldenbremse wieder eingehalten werden
schön dass sie da sind und mein name ist
lena schicke ich freue mich dass sich
ihre gastgeberin heute abend sein darf
meine these heute abend des corona test
fiasko muss aufgearbeitet werden die
bürger test sind hier ab ersten juli
eigentlich immer kosten bis zum ersten
juli immer kostenlos gewesen jetzt
werden sie aber kostenpflichtig außerdem
ausnahmefall der grund
gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach
sagte im zdf dass man sich im test nicht
mehr leisten können laut lauterbach
lagen die ausgaben teilweise bei einer
milliarde pro monat ich möchte heute gar
nicht darüber debattieren ob der test
jetzt sinnvoll sind oder waren
wie es weitergehen sollte mir geht es um
das mangelnde unternehmertum der politik
die milliarde pro monat kommt auch
zusammen beim missbrauch mit unserem
steuergeld betrieben wurde jeder konnte
ein testcenter gründen es war nicht nur
ärzte oder apotheker geführt hat jeder
ein testzentrum aufgebaut und die anzahl
der angeblich durchgeführten tests
konnten am anfang per strichliste
notiert werden das hat uns ja auch ein
apotheker vor wenigen tagen erzählt ohne
personalien das ist kein scherz
ermittler gehen von einem schaden durch
erfundene test von mehr als einer
milliarde euro aus kontrollen der
privaten test betriebe waren anfangs von
der regierung nicht vorgesehen das
änderte sich erst als wdr ndr und sz
über den fall medien berichteten der
test am betreiber aus bochum hat
gestanden erfundene test abgerechnet zu
haben der schaden soll allein in diesem
fall 25 millionen euro betragen auch der
für die tests gezeigt preis war vor
allem am anfang meiner meinung nach zu
hoch der bund zahlte den betreibern von
testzentren 11 eur 50 protest drei euro
fünfzig pauschale für den test selbst
und acht euro für weitere kosten die
anfallen auch der apothekerverband
nordrhein geht von preisen um die 20
euro aus wenn lauterbach also sagt wir
können uns die kostenlosen test nicht
mehr leisten muss ja nicht vor allem
sagen wir haben einen wahnsinnig
schlechten job gemacht und damit ist
meine erste frage heute an ihren sparen
ob ich vielleicht zu schaffen ob meine
these stimmt oder wie das mit den test
ab blieb also zuerst einmal und deswegen
werde ich nicht viel dazu sagen habe ich
ein einfaches prinzip wussten nicht dass
sie so viel krone heute machen ich
äußere mich nicht zu aktuellen kroner
politik weil ich finde das macht man
nicht ich finde das bringt auch
deutschland nicht weiter wenn minister
ihre nachfolger ex minister ihre
nachfolger kommentieren oder umgekehrt
deswegen bin ich da sehr zurückhaltend
was aktuell
muss ja nicht
immer sagen ich kann halt nur 1 nochmal
grundsätzlich sagen das ist ein gutes
jahr her und es sollte halt natürlich
über über nacht mehr oder weniger eine
test infrastruktur entstehen kostenlose
tests aus laos novelle heraus sollte uns
das führen und dinge die schnell ändern
sie haben sich entscheiden sonst perfekt
sein oder dort schnell gehen kann man
natürlich im studio ein jahr später
sagen bleibt hätte anders und so ist
alles okay akzeptiere ich auch aber es
sollte halt ziemlich schnell gehen und
es sollte flächendeckend seien selbst in
meinem heimatdorf für münsterland bei
meinen eltern 3700 einwohner gab es der
teststationen
und viele deutsche haben dadurch schon
die erfahrung gemacht ist das eigentlich
schon angenehm einfach war diesen test
zu machen
und wenn sie jetzt über die kosten reden
ich werde das personal die textstelle
das kostet halt auch und es wurde sehr
klar gesagt wenn ihr das irgendwie
halbiert könnte es gleich ganz vergessen
und jetzt gar keine anbieten also die
frage wie viel würde man sagen wenn wir
haben 80 millionen deutsche ein test
kommt streiten ob 12 oder 15 euro wenn
jeder wenn jeder nur einmal die woche im
test macht statistisch und viele haben
in den wellen auf 2.345 manche tägliche
test gemacht was alles möglich war und
ok dann kommen halt diese summen die
hoch sind aber im zweifel zum lockdown
und den kosten eines locker uns dann
immer doch noch mal anders dann kommen
diese summen zusammen mehr also wenn ich
einmal noch mal nachhaken darf ich
versteh ich finde es sogar sympathisch
dass sie nicht über den nachfolger
sprechen wollen ich finde das wirklich
angenehm weil ich finde das nachtreten
auch nicht gut aber nochmal aber wenn
man ja auch mal zeit geben wo sie dafür
verantwortlich meint über lauterbach wie
oft genug sehen sie denn jetzt nicht
rückblicken dass sie sagen vielleicht
hätte man es nur apotheker und ärzte
durchführen lassen sollen oder
vielleicht hätten wir noch mehr auf den
betrug machen sollen manchmal gibt es ja
auch eine selbstreflexion wo man jetzt
sagt naja bei dem test hätten wir auch
das eine oder andere besser machen
könnte man im nachhinein auch manches
aber sie sind ich weiß habe ich das
gesehen habe die kassenärztlichen
vereinigungen haben gerade gesagt unter
den bedingungen werden sie diese tests
nicht mehr abrechnen also werden sie
nicht mehr tun weil weil das einfach
nicht mehr geht dann ist halt die frage
die alle die jetzt dann sagen da muss
man irgendwie es anders so einfach ist
das gar nicht ist irgendwie anders zu
machen wo es gar keine direkte beziehung
des bundesministeriums zur apotheke wir
haben ja keine finanzbeziehungen wurde
das ministerium irgendwie an die
apotheken was auszahlt sondern es hat
alles eben eben seine wege klar kann man
immer was anders machen aber ich sage
ihnen wenn die tests zu in apotheken und
arztpraxen stattgefunden hätten hätten
meine eltern bescheinigt in ihrem dorf
keine testangebot gehabt habe herr
sparen sie verstehen dass ich mich über
die strichliste gewundert und auch
geärgert habe als bürgerin als ich
gehört habe man musste konnte einfach
strichlisten machen und am anfang musste
man nicht mal die personalien für den
der den test also wo der test
durchgeführt wurde aufnehmen da habe ich
mich schon geärgert als bürgerin muss
ich ihnen ehrlich sagen bei allem
respekt davor und sie haben recht als im
studio immer leichter ist darüber zu
reden deswegen bin ich auch journalisten
nicht politikerin ich gebe ehrlich zu
aber das mit der strichliste sozusagen
erstmal versuchen mich dazu jetzt mehr
ja wenn es so leicht wäre das system zu
ende dann hätte herr meier mit der ampel
koalition ja im dezember ist geändert
ich meine seiner seite ziemlich exakt
acht monaten gilt das system fort weil
es offensichtlich nicht ganz so einfach
ist ist einfach zu ändern aber das ist
jetzt das ist jetzt ein bisschen einfach
ersparen auch wenn sie jetzt dazu nichts
mehr sagen wollen dass also das test
chaos das reiht sich ja was die gesamte
corona politik ein in ganz andere auch
dem ich will das gar nicht über 2g 3g
schule zu et cetera diskutiert da kommt
nachher zu aber masken beschaffungs
chaos test chaos impfstoff beschaffungs
chaos und bei all diesen themen haben
sie als zuständiger minister die
zentrale verantwortung und ich glaube
schreibe beantworten die ampel besser
geworden er sage ich gleich aber ich
möchte schon da weil sie eben erklärt
haben dass das alles natürlich nicht
einfach und profan ist die man so ein
test organisiert dass sie alles richtig
aber in den ersten tests verordnungen
genau quasi die
notwendigkeit der überprüfung von test
center betreibern nicht drin ist dann
ist das original ihr politisches
verhalten ich habe nicht so extrem sein
wie in berlin das denn also auch
gesuchte mit haftbefehl haftbefehl
gesuchte personen im testcenter
aufmachen können aber die politische
verantwortung dafür haben sie und was
wir jetzt gemacht haben ist in der tat
zu sagen
wir können uns diese tests infrastruktur
in dieser form nicht mehr leisten
deswegen haben wir jetzt eine
kostenbeteiligung eingeführt das ging
nicht sofort das war
eine ausnahme sehr genau dass wir hätten
uns da als fdp durchaus euro mehr
vorstellen können auch was die
länderbeteiligung angeht weil warum muss
der bund immer alles übernehmen das
gehört ja auch dazu dass in dieser
pandemie situation der bund eigentlich
alles übernommen hat während die länder
sich dann sehr schlanken die
bundesländer ein sehr schlanken fuß
gemacht haben und so glaube ich kommt
man im ergebnis zu eindeutig fairen
lastenausgleich ist es ja nicht so dass
die bürger nur über die bürger tests
sich testen millionen von menschen
testen sich täglich freiwillig weil sie
sich ein test in der apotheke oder im
internet bestellt haben und haben damit
den ersten schnelltest der glaube ich an
vier stellen bestimmt genauso effizient
ist
mach das mal was seit acht monate genau
aber ich will mich nicht falsch stehen
bleibt es konnte sich niemand einfach
selbst zur testzentrum erklären auch
schon zu beginn nicht sondern es musste
das gesundheitsamt vor ort die einem
offiziell die genehmigung geben dafür
dass man ein testzentrum ist und das ist
im föderalen staat so
werde die bundesstaaten die bundes ist
ganz normales handeln das macht jede
bundesregierung auch die von ihm
getragene da wir keine verwaltung in der
fläche haben dass man aufgaben festlich
die vor ort umgesetzt werde das ist ganz
normales föderales handeln und es war
und ist aufgabe der behörden vor ort den
testzentren eine wenn man so nennen will
genehmigungen dafür zu geben dass sie
überhaupt abrechnen dürfen und ich hatte
unterstellt ja und das würde ich auch
bis heute unterstellen wollen zumindest
man wird ja nicht zuletzt in berlin
immer öfter eines besseren belehrt dass
bevor man eine textstelle genehmigt sie
sich mal anschaut die räumlichkeiten zum
beispiel an schaut sich das personal an
schaut und schaut was da gemacht werden
soll es sind aber erst alle angeschaut
wurden natürlich in berlin ist es
offenkundig nicht der fall so aber das
ist es ist aber im verein miteinander
das kann man hier immer alles so einfach
machen aber in der situation auch eine
welle wo die entscheidung ansteht muss
man sich ja irgendwie auch aufeinander
verlassen können und auf die
unterschiedlichen institutionen die eben
dann nach einer entsprechenden
verordnung eine entsprechende aufgabe
haben und ich habe er kritik gekriegt am
anfang von ländern und kommunen die
gesagt haben die anforderungen sind zu
hoch wir müssen hier viel zu viel
kontrollieren das muss doch schnell
gehen so deswegen ist das alles okay was
wird das was man da aus heutiger sicht
sagt akzeptiere ich auch ich will nur
die gelegentlich darauf hinweisen dass
die debatte vor eineinviertel jahre eine
etwas andere warten also er
zusammenfassend gesagt viel geld ist weg
oder sicht der mensch eine milliarde
laut einem monat als sich der menschen
die ehrlich ihre steuern zahlen ist das
ein bisschen traurig so könnte man es
vielleicht zusammenfassen
ich möchte gerne in einen
größeren zusammenhang stellen in ein
kontinuum deutscher politik der letzten
jahre ganz großkotzig gesagt die ja
immer durch ein ganz großes maß an
vertrauen in den menschen geprägt war
und darin dass der mensch gut ist und zu
nichts böses im stande ist
so ist zu 2015 gekommen heute sagen alle
wir wollen das nie wieder dass sich das
wiederholt man hat gedacht egal menschen
ein kommenden jahre man hat leute zu
wenig überprüft ja man hat identitäten
nicht festgestellt man hat sich auch auf
lügenmärchen erzählen lassen das wissen
wir ja alle irgendwie kommt mir das ein
bisschen bekannt vor wenn ich das jetzt
mit diesen neueren erlebnissen annika
stellen vergleiche man hat ja recht
links heimann könnte man vergleichen
auch von den privaten anbietern ja ja ja
ja das ist ja ähnliche entwicklung
gegeben ein anderes beispiel
man war ja fest davon überzeugt dass ein
so reizen der manager putin zu nichts
böses im stande sein könnte auch das hat
sich als etwas zu naiv herausgestellt
ich will jetzt hier nicht hin besser
bisher spielen also ich werde bestimmt
hätte bestimmt auch ganz viele fehler
gemacht aber das ist auffällig wenn man
das so von außen beobachtet ja ohne zu
sagen ich jetzt besser gemacht ja ganz
bescheiden
fällt auf dass sony wied und zu viel
vertrauen
in das gut sein des menschen so eine art
grund probleme unseres landes zu sein
scheint
ja also ich muss auch sagen viele haben
sich einfach bereichert an der ganzen
corona pandemie muss man auch mal sagen
also jetzt auch mit dem test oder wenn
es doch diese masken die jetzt und was
nicht alles in der presse so umgegangen
ist und ich finde die leute müssen
einfach zur verantwortung gezogen werden
egal wer es jetzt getan hat aber es geht
einfach so nicht und auch sich der
bürger die ich ja hier vertreten ist
einfach so dass viele ungerechtigkeiten
passiert sind und klar das leben ist
nicht wer aber wir können einfach nicht
so hängen gelassen werden viele von uns
haben fahrräder existenten verloren
viele meiner kollegen zum beispiel in
der unterhaltungsbranche sie musste
insolvenz anmelden und viele haben auch
selbstmord begangen weil sie einfach mit
dem ganzen druck nicht mal klarkommen
und dann gibt es da andere die sich dann
einfach daran bereichern und das ist in
ordnung das ist sehr schlimm und ein
guter übergang zu ihrem thema in haben
auch wenn sie nur einen punkt weil er
betrug nicht nur da sondern leider auch
an anderen stellen immer bei den
wirtschaftshilfen und dann aber dann
sieht man halt mal die einen sagen
wahrscheinlich die nicht so viel haben
nicht so viele auflagen nicht so viel
papier werden muss man doch schnell und
sie machen gerade für mittelständler für
kleine für selbständige warum müssen die
so viel ausfüllen und nachweisen
überweist denen das geld so war die
stimmung aber leider ja herr martenstein
sind nicht alle menschen gut und gerecht
sondern auch da haben leute dann
betrogen und haben geld erstmal sich
überweisen lassen dass ihnen nie
zugestanden hätte das ist auch alles ja
dann verfolgt worden aber dann sind die
auflagen erhöht wurde und auf einmal
wurden die november hilfen ich weiß
keiner mehr märz glaube ich ausgezahlt
weil dann aus der erfahrung nicht sich
verlassen sondern kontrollieren dann die
verfahren auf einmal viel komplexer und
anspruchsvoller
ich will ja ich bin ja ich natürlich
auch begraben doch nur ich will doch
einfach nur mal sagen das ist am ende
geht es dann so ein bisschen um die wahl
und mike ryan von der weko hat das mal
speed beats perfekten genannt in einer
krise geschwindigkeit oder perfektion
schnelle hilfe wirtschaftshilfe in für
leute die es echt schwer hatten die von
existenz veranstalten geschrieben da ja
auch nicht jemand da es wurde halt ist
wurde doch halt am ende hatte ich will
den hörer an dem beispiel zeigen
wirtschaftshilfen mit dem betrug kam
mehr auflagen und schon dauert ist
natürlich länger und und deswegen ist
dass dieser dieser spagat indem sie sind
und das ist einfach noch mal ein
beispiel dafür da habe ich ihn trotzdem
noch eine letzte frage bei meiner these
zu ihrer zeit stellen die ist sogar
persönlich wie schwer war es denn sie
haben es ja eben angesprochen man ist
dann kein journalist politiker muss es
machen wie schwer waren das amt war es
auch in manchen zeiten würde
ich habe das gern gemacht so ich hätte
so gern weil tatsächlich
regierenden unterschied macht und in
dieser pandemie die ja auch immer noch
da ist war das schon für eine besondere
verantwortung verpflichtung zugleich bei
jeder tag immer super natürlich nicht
aber das war es für niemanden in dieser
schwierigen zeit dass das das ist so ich
habe alle alle höhen und tiefen erlebt
in diesen zwei jahren politisch aber
viel wichtiger ist dieses land ist durch
eine recht schwere zeit gegangen und das
hat auch zu spannungen zurückgelassener
schicksale zurückgelassen familien die
hart getroffen worden sind und damit in
verantwortung gewesen zu sein dass das
ist ja nicht heute machen oder so das
habe ich einfach auch als das empfunden
weswegen ich mal in die politik gegangen
bin dass man da eben verantwortung
übernimmt auch in schwerin sein und der
einstieg sehr sitzt ja neben in frage
aber sie haben schon angefangen davon zu
erzählen je thema auch für heute abend
ist ja dass die korona panini auch mit
ihrer branche auch mit ihm selbst
gemacht hat ja also ich lese
stellvertretend für die ganze
veranstaltungsbranche und da ist halt
nicht unbedingt nur der künstler wie ich
so richtig der auf der bühne aber auch
bühnentechnik bühnenlicht security ist
der brezel verkäufer dass so eine
riesengroße branche die einfach
vernachlässigt worden ist und wir haben
dann keine hilfen bekommen und zum
beispiel habe ich jetzt auch vorhin mit
einer meiner kolleginnen telefoniert und
die meinte sie wurden als
scheinselbstständige angezeigt aber sie
konnten zu arbeiten sie hat ja kein
berufsverbot bekommen aber sie konnte ja
nicht arbeiten weil sie in der
bühnentechnik arbeitet und es gab
einfach keine bühne zum aufbauen und da
fand ich war es schon sehr kritisch und
dann hat man halt dann entfernten tut
mir leid da ich das sage aber man hat
dann gesehen der eine kauft sich eine
riesenvilla werden wir alle hier ja uns
ums überleben kämpfen also ich wusste
nicht wie ich meine miete zahlen soll
und ich habe sie wirklich verflucht am
fernsehen und klar ich würde auch gerne
nicht mit ihm tauschen also ich habe
riesen respekt dass die politiker sind
gerade jetzt mit der wirtschaft an
gesundheit und auch der umwelt das alles
unter einen hut zu kriegen ist
superschwer und deswegen vertrauen der
bürger eben auf politiker und hoffen
dass die unsere besten also bestmöglich
dass auch vertreten aber wir fühlen uns
dann auch leicht verarscht wenn wir dann
so sachen hören was nicht der den deal
gemacht der den deal und die werden alle
reinschauen hier hätte es ist besser für
sie gemacht wenn beispielsweise ein
spitzenpolitiker wir sparen eine
einzelmeinung
nein auf keinen fall ich meine er
verdient alles was er hat wie es
erworben hat es auch nicht mein ding was
mich halt freud hätte wenn wir ein
bisschen mehr sicherheit gehabt hätten
ich zum beispiel wusste also ich hab ne
show geplant am 29 04 und keiner wusste
man hat gesehen in china geht es da los
und man wusste wirklich man hat angst
gehabt und genau am 29 04 ist der
lockdown gekommen ich habe alles
verloren die ganzen ticket ich habe die
ganzen flüge die ich gebucht habe ich
habe keine chance und dann wusste man
nicht wie geht es weiter und dann hat
man immer die verkauften tickets aber
verschoben die show wird dann
stattfinden aber dann hat man gesagt im
dezember aber man konnte nicht planen
und auch jetzt ich habe im oktober jetzt
meine zwei nächsten shows und ich hoffe
dass sie mich wieder aus meinen
schuldenberg rausholen geplant aber ich
weiß ja gar nicht ob sie stattfinden
dürfen wir es jetzt wieder heißt herbst
könnte es sein dass sagen wieder chaos
gibt und dann waren auch so
ungerechtigkeiten zum beispiel ich war
in einer halle 2000 leute reinpassen ich
durfte aber nur 50 prozent auslasten
also durfte nur 500 rein während im
fußball aber 20.000 leute waren und dann
dachte ich wieso darf ich nicht 1000
leute meine halle haben wir haben nur
geimpfte und genesen reingelassen wir
haben masken pflicht gehabt wir alle
auflagen erfüllt aber trotzdem haben wir
nur verlust gemacht und es war wirklich
wirklich schwer ja ich können uns aber
auch eins vielleicht eigentlichen das
virus ist ja das problem also es geht
mir manchmal so ein bisschen unter dass
da ein virus über die welt gekommen ist
dass das den unterschied gemacht hat das
hat sich ein anderer länder haben es
aber doch auch hinbekommen schweden
ich weiß jetzt nicht ich bin ja immer
ganz also ich wüsste nicht so viele
andere länder als deutschland in denen
ich gerne gewesen wäre die besten
zweieinhalb jahre dann kommt vielleicht
noch späten manchmal rufen die
demonstranten russland zog dann sage ich
herzlichen glückwunsch wenn ihr meint
dass ihr in russland auch nur einer
dieser demo
entgegen gekommen ich hab ich hab
demonstrationen erlebt wo ich am ende
nur noch eine frage hatte weil das
gespräch einfach nicht möglich war in
welchem land wäre ja eigentlich lieber
und anrufen tatsächlich leute man steht
ja staunte vor russland aber das ist
nicht der punkt der punkt ist dass das
halt ne echt
beschwerliche zeit auf ihn war wegen
eines virus aber ich lege
unter gefahr die da war und am ende ging
es ja darum damit umzugehen als
gesellschaft jeder einzelne und
natürlich auch als politiker ist alles
richtig gelaufen ein offenkundig nicht
und ich bleibe aber trotzdem dabei das
alles in allem dieses land verglichen
auch mit vielen anderen vergleichs
übrigens auch wirtschaftlich es gab
nicht so viele länder auf der welt die
in dem umfang haben wirtschaftlich
unterstützt wenn wir nicht heran die
andere leute das wird überhaupt nicht
abgewogen also ich meine die schäden die
durch maßnahmen eingetreten sind werden
finde ich nicht fair abgewohnte
wirtschaft gegenposition perfekte das
und die dinge sind auch teilweise
wahnsinnig widersprüchlichen gewesen
haben den leuten nicht eingeleuchtet zum
beispiel die schulschließung wir wissen
inzwischen also wenn sie ein
kind haben das psychologische hilfe
braucht dann müssen sie inzwischen ich
weiß nicht jahre glaube ich warten bis
er einen therapieplatz bekommen die
kinder sind mit ihrer seelischen kraft
am ende vieler und das ist eine folge
dieser schulschließungen gewesen man hat
die folge ich mache das niemandem
persönlich zum vorwurf niemand auch
ihnen nicht jeder von uns dass die
situation war nie da gewesen man hat
sich sozusagen mit zu einem blindenstock
durchs dunkel getastet das wissen wir
doch alle aber man darf auch hinterher
nicht schönreden und so tun als ob alles
super gelaufen wäre und ein bisschen tun
sie dass das was sie mit den schulen
daran gestört haben die länder das ist
nicht super gelaufen die
schulschließungen waren ein großer
fehler und wir hoffen alle ich hab auch
einen kleinen sohn noch wir hoffen alle
dass sich diese barbarische geschichte
dieses schulschließungen nicht
wiederholt jedenfalls nicht solange es
nicht wirklich überzeugende medizinische
gründe dafür gibt also gut aber wir
reden wir eigentlich wollen sie ja gar
nicht darüber reden sind so ins gespräch
gekommen entsprechend
aber bartenstein
ist okay ich weiß jetzt wortgewaltig
lesen ihre texte
das ist ja nicht so dass eine einzige
dieser entscheidung eine einzige
irgendjemandem leicht gefallen wäre
glauben sie dass da irgendwas von
leistungen und am ende des tages ist das
ja alles nicht passiert weil
irgendjemand die wahrheit hatte hainer
hatte die wahrheit und das ist eine
abwehr ja weil ich fänds auf ihrer seite
abwehren
dahinter hält ich sagen ist es gut
gewesen ich habe mich betätigte letzte
also wenn wir haben besser durch den
also alle anträge gesagt habe doch nicht
gesagt dass alles super war ich bin
wirklich der letzte der einfach nur
alles gesund
sie hätten sich nicht zwei gegebene 2
plus und so gut was nicht gut das ist ja
okay wenn sie das alle anders sehen ich
mache die erfahrung dass ich bleibe
dabei ziemlich viele in diesem land
alles in allem stand finden dass wir gut
und vielleicht besser doch als viele
andere länder auf der welt durch diese
schwere zeit gekommen sind in der
gesamtschau es geht ja im übrigen auch
um die frage wie wirtschaftlich
durchgekommen sind neben anderen stellen
durchgekommen sind aber natürlich ist
das und da darf man auch die augen nicht
verschließen
also ich habe sehr früh begonnen auch
mit mit kinder- und jugendärzten
psychiatern auch gespräche zu führen
darüber zu reden wie wir auch da
angebote machen können alles was sie tun
hat immer auch folgen ja und es ist es
ist so dass gesundheit prioritär war
aber nicht absolut in keinem zeitpunkt
absolut ist kein serie core wird habe
ich nie was von gehalten gegen nicht
darum jeden einzelne infektionen zu
vermeiden es ging darum ein
gesundheitssystem vor der überlastung zu
schützen das war der punkt um den es
ging nicht darum jedes einzelne leben
das können sie nämlich nichts kann sie
bei keiner krankheit bei einer infektion
bei dem man die aloe blacc macht so und
dann ja genau weil zum beispiel die
frage war
nun das wusste das wusste jedenfalls
zudem entscheidungspunkte niemand im
übrigen ich habe mit heiner garg ist ja
nicht so als wenn jetzt die fdp dass ich
habe mit heiner garg als
gesundheitsminister der fdp in schleswig
holstein die dinge genauso gesprochen
wie mit der linken
gesundheitsministerinnen thöring und es
war eine ziemlich einheitliche
einschätzung setzt kann man immer sagen
anlagen alle 17 falsch aber es war jetzt
nicht irgendwie sozusagen eine eine eine
eine parteipolitische verantwortung
sondern eher eine in der abwägung des
schutzes der freiheit des einzelnen und
der gesundheit auch das einzelnen
anderen aspekten im schutz des neben
sitzenden in der pandemie und das
gesundheits bild waren sie machen es
sich das ist die abwägung dass ich hier
wirklich zu einfach sie haben natürlich
recht diese situation war noch nie da
und am ende des tages
werden in so einer situation auch fehler
gemacht aber ein bisschen mehr reflexion
wir werden ja morgen den
evaluationsbericht bekommen wäre doch
gut und dann geht es jetzt noch nicht
mal darum ob man weiß wie man mit so
einer pandemie umgeht wie man die
abwägung unterschiedlicher
grundrechte freiheit einschränkung
kindswohl aber das leben ist aber wie
viel hat sich geändert seit die antwort
schuldig wir haben eben sagt vorgabe hat
das sie sich wünschen jetzt für für den
herbst sie haben wieder keine
planungssicherheit also eigentlich das
habe ich auch schon vor allem sprechen
wir wären also da erstmals hat ist dass
wir erstmal evidenzbasiert vorgehen
wollen dem wir sagen wir wollen die
bisherigen corona massnahmen evaluieren
wir bekommen diesen evolution berichten
morgen und wir werden weitere maßnahmen
anhand dieses evolution berichtes
diskutieren in der ampel unabhängig
davon wie jetzt die einzelnen positionen
oder angst und dem bericht also
das haben wir mit den änderungen im
infektionsschutzgesetz eine märz einen
hotspot regel aufgesetzt die am ende des
tages eine freiheit für millionen von
menschen bedeutet hätte die kollegen von
herrn spahn aus der union vor allem aber
auch teilweise von den sozialdemokraten
grünen waren eher der auffassung dass
wir in ascha der den bundestagswahlkampf
gesagt mit ihm wird das geht ab dann
gehen wir dass wir im märz april mai
noch im weiteren sinne zweig gehabt
hätten weiter einzelhandel irgendwo
gebastelten betreten können
großveranstaltungen studenten
durchgeführt können deshalb alles die
fdp in den verhandlungen durchgesetzt
wir haben das ganze thema impfpflicht
debatte die am ende auch maßgeblich
daran oder im ergebnis dazu geführt dass
wir keine impfpflicht
bekommen haben im april diesen jahres
mit einem impfstoff der noch auf eine
ganz andere
version geeichte war weil die mehrheit
der fdp dies verhindert hat wir haben
das thema test bürger tests wir hätten
gerne auch schon im oktober letzten
jahres da die situation verändert hat
muss man sagen dass die
vorgängerregierung da haben sie herr
sparen dafür gesorgt dass nicht genug
impfstoff zur verfügung steht im herbst
wenn also die nächste welle anrollt
sodass wir testen mussten zu der
damaligen zeit um ein lagebild zu haben
das wird in diesem herbst anders sein
weil wir uns mit genug impfstoff
bestellungen jetzt so bevorratet haben
dass wir die leute mit einer politik mal
gearbeitet eine planungssicherheit ich
glaube schon dass eine
planungssicherheit der gestalte da ist
dass wir sicherstellen werden das ist ja
die evolution die jetzt kommt aber auch
aus anderen europäischen ländern dass
wir als fdp sicherlich kein lockdown
mehr mitgehen werden ab jetzt gerade sie
oft ein bisschen uns jetzt noch impfen
also hätte sie lange soll das noch vor
spanien die neue variante sind da habe
ich ja so da hat herr spahn da hat herr
sparen natürlich dergestalt recht dass
diese pandemie für uns alle neu ist ich
glaube schon dass es eine sehr gute
empfehlung wäre wenn man sich vor dem
herbst noch einmal impfen lässt mit
einem impfstoff der jetzt an die
mutation
angeglichen ist dass wir aber irgendwann
sicherlich in die situation kommen
werden dass auch das nicht mehr nötig
ist wie ein leben jetzt ja gerade ich
glaube die bild hat heute sogar irgendwo
die das ungleichgewicht der instanzen im
osten deutschlands zu westdeutschland
herausgearbeitet was gegebenenfalls
daran dann hatten wir die nebenwirkungen
durch die impfung auf seite 1 was aber
daran was aber daran lag dass
viele geimpfte im ostdeutschland bereits
mit corona auch infiziert waren dadurch
also die widerstandsfähigkeit stärker
geworden ist natürlich wird am ende des
tages diese pandemie auslaufen und wir
werden dann sicherlich keine
ständige impfung mehr durchführen haben
wir schon sagen sie da gibt es natürlich
gibt es bei manchen nebenwirkungen es
gibt bei jedem impfstoffen und es ist
sicherlich auch so dass es hier
vereinzelt stärkere nebenwirkungen
gegeben hat aber in würde leben in der
abwägung dass wir mit den impfen
hunderttausenden von menschen das leben
gerettet haben und einen milden verlauf
sichergestellt haben das ist die
abwägung das hat der spanier durchaus zu
recht gesagt wo man abwägen muss
zwischen dann einzelfällen auf der einen
seite und dem wohl der gesamten
gesellschaft des ganzen landes und
deswegen ist das impfen nach wie vor
richtig am ende des tages ist auch
richtig dass wir keine impfpflicht haben
aber ich kann nur jedem wärmstens
empfehlen trotz der risiken die bestehen
sich impfen zu lassen auch in diesem
herrn meier wir haben sie messen auch
hierbei fiel nach 8 wie lange haben sie
ein auftreten können damit kommen jetzt
ihnen herr martenstein auch die letzte
krone at das
wäre auch
glaube ich herrn spahn einen ganz
einfachen gesprächspartner sein der
runde weil ich finde dass wir uns jetzt
mal der zukunft zuwenden sollte nicht
dem was in der vergangenheit gemacht
worden ist sondern wie es weitergeht
morgen ist ja ein besonderer tag in der
pandemie geschichte da wird dieser
sogenannte evaluationsbericht
vorgestellt das heißt experten oder
regierung ausgewählte experten haben
sich die diversen massnahmen angeschaut
und geprüft welche viel gebracht haben
die lok downs die masken die
schulschließung was hat was gebracht und
was nicht
dieser bericht wird schon heftig
kritisiert bevor ihn überhaupt
irgendeine gelesen hat herr lauterbach
scheint vor dieser evaluation angst zu
haben wie der teufel vor dem weihwasser
es gibt mittlerweile ja auch ein
verstärkt er heißt wir wollen masken
pflicht ja es gibt eine in der
gesellschaft ein willen bei vielen gar
nicht so wenigen auf keinen fall aus
dieser pandemie irgendwie raus so
gleiten ja herr montgomery der
ärztefunktionär ist auch so ein fall und
zwar das ist das erstaunliche relativ
unabhängig von der lage in der man sich
befindet wie die lage im herbst und
winter sein wird kann niemand wissen es
ist unbekanntes gelände tweedy zukunft
im allgemeinen wie ist die lage heute
die lage heute bedeutet ist sieht so aus
dass von einer überlastung des
gesundheitssystems und intensivstationen
keine rede sein kann ich glaube damit
ersparen wenn ich widersprechen und dass
die inzidenz
infektionszahlen nicht mehr die
bedeutung haben diese zu beginn der
pandemie hatten weil wir es mit einem in
der regel in der regel milden verlauf zu
tun haben das ändert nichts daran dass
man risikogruppen zu erspielen menschen
in altenheim besonders schützen muss
aber insgesamt ist die gefahrenlage doch
eine andere sie am anfang gewesen ist
und mein eindruck ist und da finde ich
sollte man wachsam sein also die
gesellschaft wirklich aufpassen dass man
uns in einen dritten corona winter
hinein also geistig gesehen ihn
einprügeln möchte obwohl das die reale
lage möglicherweise gar nicht hergibt
ich sage dazu um nicht missverstanden zu
werden wenn
übermorgen ein eine gefährlichere
variante um die ecke biegt oder wenn
tatsächlich die
intensivstation wieder voll auf muss man
natürlich völlig neu nachdenken dann
muss man was machen ich bin ja nicht
gegen maßnahmen aber ich bin dagegen und
ich bin dreimal geimpft und alles ich
habe alles mitgemacht und zwar aus
überzeugung jetzt nicht ungefährt nicht
nicht weil man irgendwelchen druck auf
mich ausgeübt hätte hat niemand
aber
wenn wir
freiheitsrechte kassieren wenn wir das
leben der leute regulieren man kann da
das machen aber man muss triftige gründe
dafür haben finde ich es muss gründe
dafür geben man kann das nicht pi mal
daumen oder aus dem bauchgefühl heraus
machen und diesen diesen eindruck habe
ich im moment wir haben
in deutschland und also ich muss wieder
auf deutschland zu sprechen kommen also
offensichtlich ein größeres angst und
panik potenzial als anderswo also und
ich höre ja auch wenn ich das radio oder
fernseher anschalte ja auch pausenlos
ein panikorchester spielen ja ich und in
unseren nachbarländern sieht das halt
doch vielleicht mentalitätsmäßig ein
bisschen anders aus ich bin kürzlich mit
der eisenbahn nach holland gefahren sie
glauben gar nicht wie sich das leben
verändert sobald sie die niederländische
grenze überschritten haben in den bussen
und u bahnen keine masken pflicht in den
zügen keine massen glauben sie die rolle
der wollen aussterben sind die alle
irgendwie suizid gefährdet oder sind sie
alle blöde ich glaube nicht also bei
colin haben generell ein anderes
naturell
aber in anderen hält dänemark tschechien
da bin ich auch gewesen ich habe ein
paar mal so zu sagen wie landes das land
verlassen ja immer legal und
unter ist und da ist es eben da ist die
stimmung einfach eine etwas andere ich
will das jetzt gar nicht groß
kritisieren ich will nur sagen damit
dass wir wirklich aufpassen müssen dass
wir nicht ohne wirklich überzeugende
gründe in diesen in diesen diesen
dritten
corona winter eingetrieben werden folge
arbeit würden dass die bürger denn
überhaupt noch mitmachen kronawetter
schwer zu sagen aber ich finde auch wie
ihr schon sagt wir dürfen nicht so viel
panik machen wir dürfen die leute nicht
so trennen also ich so mächtig wie jetzt
gerade auf deutschlandtournee und wir
haben sehr strenge krone regeln und wir
müssen nun mal die massige den ganzen
tag tragen was ich auch gerne mache also
ob es nur um 80 gibt oder nicht ich
würde trotzdem eine maske tragen und ich
werde aber mal ganz schief von den
leuten angeguckt und dann gibt es
wirklich zwei seiten und die einzelteile
für diese maßnahmen und die anderen
gehen und das wird die ganze zeit so
auch da wo ich jetzt wohne in balingen
sind sehr viele querdenker und man merkt
schon wie die leute so aggressiv
untereinander die bürger untereinander
aber ich denke schon dass wir natürlich
mit der presse aber auch mit der politik
zu tun weil die stacheln ist auch schon
die ganze zeit an und man hört halt
wirklich nur dieses eine thema oder
corona jetzt der krieg und weltkrieg es
gibt eigentlich nur probleme und
deswegen möchte ich unbedingt in der
veranstaltungsbranche meine shows machen
damit ich die leute bisher auf andere
gedanken bringen und ich hoffe dass ich
das dann auch darf im oktober meinen
eigenen shows machen weil ja die leute
sind müde und man sieht ja auch diese
ganzen konzerte die jetzt alle
stattfinden die leute wollen raus die
wollen endlich aufhören diese ganzen
sorgen zu haben und wir haben einfach
gerade sehr viele probleme und ich hoffe
dass die politik da helfen kann
weil ich muss ehrlich zugeben ich
verstehe nicht so viel volk von politik
und deswegen gebe ich eigentlich auch
wie gesagt mit vertrauen meine stimme an
die politik und hoffe dass sie es besser
machen aber gerade läuft ein sehr viel
falsch und ja wir hoffen einfach dass
alles besser wird aber ich habe ja schon
gesagt wir werden ab morgen darüber
diskutieren das kommt sicherlich auch
dazu wie die einzelnen maßnahmen zu
bewerten waren und ich kann nur sagen
dass wir die position der fdp auch
während der korona zeit und gerade jetzt
auch in den letzten monaten dass wir
keine freiheit eingriffe mehr zulassen
werden weil es nur weil es der
einfachste weg ist aber es gibt auch
andere themen wie spritpreise oder die
erhöhten
kosten der im lebensmittel die fdp hat
ja auch zweig mitgetragen beispielsweise
die ausgrenzung inventar wir haben am
ende des tages
das ist richtig eine abwägung getroffen
aber man muss ja mal sagen weswegen war
dies noch nötig und deswegen
haben wir glaube ich schon dafür gesorgt
dass eine reihe von maßnahmen zunächst
erstmal in der möglichkeit die wir als
oppositionsfraktion seinerzeit hatten
parlamentsbeteiligung tor in die
richtige richtung gegangen ist und dass
wir in diesen letzten winter so
reingegangen sind das wie gesagt liegt
ein stück weiter daran dass wir den
regierungswechsel im auch erst im anfang
dezember hatten ja eine bundestagswahl
ende september
hätten sicherlich auch andere
konstellationen
das ist ja klar
lieber in jamaika verhandelt dazu war
die cdu leider sie hätten eigentlich
langsam mit herr sparen hätten wir
hatten die union schon auf den richtigen
weg gebracht nach den vergangenen 16
jahren aber unabhängig davon
der letzte winter war in den letzten
jahren war die union ja nicht immer der
letzte der letzte winter der letzte
winter war ein abbild der situation wie
wir das land vorgefunden haben und ich
kann die nur garantieren dass wir das
jetzt im kommenden herbst und damit dann
auch in vorboten auf dem winter so selig
die drei mal sehen
das kind dort gar nicht froh dass wir so
ein paar landesregierung ich meine dass
jetzt alles vorbei war in manchen landes
regierungsbeteiligung aber sie haben ja
egal sie machen das schon alles richtig
so
ganz so als hätte man mit allen nichts
zu tun dadurch gewinnen dass die letzten
16 jahre durch schon gar keine
verantwortung natürlich ein paar andere
tun können aber wenn sich die
parlamentsreden von ihnen in ihren
kollegen angucken habe man wurde das
gefühl wir müssen
wir haben nur zwei dinge unterscheiden
ja das eine ist die frage der letzten 16
jahre die übrigens alles in allem ich
meine wir hatten die letzten längste
wirtschaftswachstums zeit in der
geschichte daraus gemacht warten sie mal
kurz in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik so viele erwerbstätige
wie nie zuvor wir hatten
haushaltsüberschüsse hat es bei
fdp-regierungsbeteiligung schon lange
nicht mehr gegeben haushaltsüberschüsse
sozialversicherungen stabil das waren
schon auch viele viele gute jahre
trotzdem jahr gibt es auch themen die zu
starke abhängigkeit von russland
überhaupt gar keine frage das sind wir
dann übrigens vieles ist 2000
digitalisierung des 2009 bis 13 auch mal
wir haben alle hat eine verantwortung
mit aber es gibt zwei dinge zu trennen
aus meiner sicht das eine ist die frage
warum sind wir in der situation in der
wir jetzt sind grund der debatte stelle
ich mich auch geld und auch
selbstkritisch die andere frage ist was
passiert in der krise im krisen
management seit 34 monaten seit
kriegsbeginn hohe energiepreise was ist
mit der frage der vorbereitung für den
winter und die beiden fragen muss man
trennen und was ihr ja da versucht in
jeder debatte und im zweifel ja auch sie
gerade schon wieder damit angefangen
haben ist ja ihr wollt die debatte über
das krisenmanagement und die probleme
die es auch da gibt ein paar fragen habe
ich da jedenfalls auch die wollte immer
beenden mit dem hinweis darauf dass das
skelett dass ein neuer regierungspartner
übrigens in den letzten 16 jahren zwölf
jahre mitregiert hat ist ja dann
irgendwie auch noch teil der geschichte
deswegen stellen wir uns und ich stelle
mich da auch jeder diskussion überhaupt
gar kein gar keine frage schon der frage
was wien aber ich hab halt auch kurz
unterbrechen
gleich über die ampel nach einer ganz
kurzen unterbrechung sind wir zurück
[Musik]
also da kann ich dann ein lauter
brauchen und nicht ernst nehmen als
sogenannten experten
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren bei 14 85 köpfen fünf meinungen
von jeder von uns hat ein thema
mitgebracht was ihn bewegt freut oder
schockiert
so nicht rüber chip buschi hergiswil
wetten
aber niemand von den politischen
parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen hier einfach nur freiheit diese
grün-roten der darm führen hochtrabende
debatten über die rettung des weltklimas
und kommen die füße russland die ratten
das thema ist viel zu wichtig um es nur
der afg zu überlassen lasst den leuten
noch mal einen spaß wir sehen da etwas
was eigentlich fatale ist in der politik
bei den journalisten deren job ist es
doch gerade abweichende meinungen zu
führen und sie sollen den doch auch
richtig dürfte sein dass das gehirn
eines konnte zum manko vielleicht einmal
kurz
doch das sind übliche an dem radträger
ausgesprochen ich habe meinen beifahrer
meine sache immer bekommt er kümmert
sich darum niemand gibt ist wahr
geworden
ist er ganz knapp drüber sprechen das
einfach nicht fertig richtig wo ist die
ausgabe von journalismus einfach
die verlautbarung der politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
lesen zurück und wollen keine zeit
verlieren und kommen direkt zu dem thema
was jens spahn beschäftigt
die these dass die ampel hat ein
wackelkontakt die ist ein die schon
ziemlich runter geguckt also ich habe im
dezember als die neue regierung sich
gebildet hat nach den koalitions warnung
gedacht war das waren schon
beeindruckende koalitionsverhandlungen
das war wenig öffentlicher streit sollen
dann dachte jetzt wird richtig schwer
wahrscheinlich für so eine opposition
wenn die so reagieren wie sie
koalitionsverhandlungen geführt haben
und jetzt war ja schon im januar damit
vorbei wir werden das thema
verpflichtende impfung ja jetzt wie man
zu impfpflicht steht egal jetzt
inhaltlich aber hast ein kanzler sagt
ich bin für eine impfpflicht was sollen
wir gruppenanträge so als wenn helmut
kohl den europa gruppenantrag eingeführt
hatte also das ist ja schon mit an dass
die koalition nicht in der lage war an
der stelle einheitlich aufzutreten und
es hat sich halt bis heute fortgesetzt
ich meine dass wir jetzt diese woche
erlebt haben rund um den verbrenner
motor wo noch im bis in die abstimmung
in brüssel hinein das war nicht nur
peinlich in deutschland das war peinlich
in der ganzen europäischen union per
twitter die bundesregierung ihre
unterschiedlichen positionen
ausgetauscht
es wird jede woche was angekündigt um
die bürger zu entlasten was hohe
energiepreise angeht aber jeder machten
eigenen und anderen vorschlag
entschieden wird aber nichts
waffenlieferungen der sagen fdp
politiker das problem sitzt im
kanzleramt dass die waffen also es ist
ja so dass nicht die opposition die das
sagt innerhalb der eigenen regierung wir
sind irgendwie nach acht monaten dieser
neuen regierung die eigentlich gut
gestartet war mit
koalitionsverhandlungen
schon so weit bis hin zum twitter streit
wie wir in schlechtesten groko großen
koalition in zeiten nicht gewesen sind
also dass im umgang miteinander und das
und das in so einer krise in der zeit wo
wir zumindest mal das risiko haben dass
wenn zum beispiel gas nicht mehr
ausreichend kommt etwa für die industrie
wo wir in arbeitslosigkeit hineingehen
möglicherweise in rezessionen in
kurzarbeit in der zeit wo es mehr denn
je darauf ankommt dass
handlungsfähigkeit da ist das
entschieden wird das immer wieder auch
mal was schnell entschieden wird wenn es
darauf ankommt hat diese koalition hat
diese ampel in ziemlichen wackelkontakt
und das ist nicht gut
naja ich hab ja sparen sie müssen sich
weniger sorgen um die ampel machen dass
diese ampel keine
liebeshochzeit war zu beginn dass wir
teilweise diametral andere
politikansätze haben auch in den
wahlprogrammen haben wir immer gesagt
wir haben uns in den
koalitionsverhandlungen
miteinander
vereinbart dass wir einen anderen stil
pflegen dazu gehört aber auch dass man
die unterschiede der einzelnen partner
so in der öffentlichkeit auch durchaus
wahrnimmt das ist ja vielleicht auch ein
unterschied zur großen koalition zum
letzten zwei legislaturen große
koalition wo am ende ist das gar kein
unterschied mehr da war wer am ende
union oder spd wofür verantwortlich
war und dann haben wir in der tat eine
situation
sie hatten ein paar jahre als
gesundheitsminister in vorbereitung um
sich auch auf pandemien vorzubereiten
wir haben keine 100 tage gehabt wo wir
corona welle die noch durch den winter
durchgehend mit mangelhafter
vorbereitung der vorgängerregierung und
krieg in der ukraine aufgrund des
angriffs von russland hat so und wir
haben jetzt eine reihe von themen die
wir angehen müssen und die die gehen wir
also nur als beispiel zum thema manchmal
muss man schnell entscheiden sie und
ihre union wollten im märz ein
einseitiges gas-embargo in russland
stimmte hängen nicht auch das können wir
über twitter sehen einander ausreden
soja und da muss alle anderen schritte
für die fehler der eigenen fans ist das
ein bisschen anders so wie sich eben
versucht haben aus dem koma management
rauszureden am ende des tages muss man
die themen dann auch so bearbeiten dass
es funktioniert und der weg den sie im
märz vorgeschlagen hätten wären
massenarbeitslosigkeit gewesen wären
wirtschaftseinbruch in 67 prozent
gewesen wir haben jetzt eine situation
und da bin ich ja durchaus bei ihnen
irgendwie eine fassbare special bahnhöfe
ist es gar nicht gebe ihnen ich gebe
ihnen ich gebe ihnen durchaus recht dass
die fdp sich wünschen würde oder
gewünscht hätte dass schwere waffen
schneller an die ukraine geliefert
werden das haben wir immer gemacht ich
glaube wir
garantien oder haben auch durch unser
intervenieren im april was anträge die
sie auch mitgetragen haben im deutschen
bundestag als union klar gemacht dass
wir hier den kurs der ampel auch
entsprechend revidiert haben es ist
sicherlich so dass auch das umstellen
auf
kohlekraftwerke die jetzt im juli
anlaufen werden aus unserer perspektive
hätten schneller gehen kann das will ich
gar nicht in abrede stellen aber so zu
tun als ob wir die probleme die wir wie
gesagt 16 jahre cdu geführte
bundesregierung übernehmen übernehmen
muss stimmt könnte
ein thema das vielleicht einfach ist und
sie hat sich auch 10 jahre kohle kohle
hat
unser neuer stil jetzt können wir mal
ein thema wo sie nicht immer ist auf
andere schieben ich um diese
bundesregierung brauchte für die
abstimmung in diesem jahr wir sind in
dieser woche im rat in brüssel oder
luxemburg wo immer die geteilter eine
einheitliche position und sie war bis
zum beginn der sitzung nicht in der lage
eine einheitliche position zu haben es
ging um für deutschland geht es darum
ziemlich viel ja es ist ja so eine
debatte verbrenner autos autos sind eine
quelle unseres wohlstand ob wir uns
überhaupt irgendwas leisten können oder
nicht hat was damit zu tun ob wir autos
in die welt verkaufen soll dann erleben
wir wo es in die sitzung hinein ja bei
twitter wie die umweltministerin und der
finanzminister irgendwie irre
unterschied wir können sagen wir pflegen
unterschiedliche positionen ist unser
neuer stil aber der kann ja irgendwie
nicht bedeuten dass da in brüssel
irgendwie zwei verschiedene positionen
vertreten werden wenn man muss ja schon
an der lage sein idealerweise dass ich
teile die position der fdp und der sache
aber sie haben sich nicht durchgesetzt
ich meine am ende kriegen wir dann groß
erklärt der verbrenner motor am nächsten
morgen alle ganz stolz bleibt dann gehst
du dir die texte durch was wer nicht
beschlossen worden und am ende ist euer
kleiner aufstand da per twitter als
papiertiger gelandet wenn das der neue
stil das regieren sind angedacht
die hassen aber nur einsatz also wenn
der größte deutsche automobilzulieferer
bosch mit dem gefundenen kompromiss was
uns angeht zufrieden ist das auch in
interviews sagt dann aber er ganz viele
mittelständische automobilzulieferer die
überhaupt nicht zufrieden sagte ich wir
hätten uns eine andere position
gewünscht die kommissionspräsidentin
frau von der leyen cdu parteibuch trat
mit ihrem fit sind immer andere
schneiden das
gericht wissen
da sollen die wände kleinteilig gar
nicht
welcher perspektive zunächst erhält man
eine politisierung kam und das
verbrenner aus kam nicht von der fdp als
position es wurde von der
unionsregierten bundesregierung
eingeführt und die werbung also beste
daraus sogar nach dass die fdp haben
ohne uns damit ist das andere geht nicht
um die fdp es geht darum dass wir eine
regierung haben aus drei parteien ja wo
wir jeden tag und das war jetzt ein
beispiel die ein die bürger sagen wann
kommt endlich unsere entlastung die
einen sagen soziales klima geld die
anderen machen tank rabatt oder steuern
senken die dritten kommen irgendwie auch
noch mit einer idee der kanzler hat
jetzt auch eine idee gehabt diese
einmalzahlung muss man ja vorstellen der
kanzler der bundesrepublik deutschland
einmalzahlungen aus der einmalzahlung
wird eine eintagsfliege
zwei tage später redet schon niemand
mehr darüber was der kanzler
deutschlands gesagt hat in der koalition
ist es leicht zu den akten gelegt worden
und da bin ich halt bei dem punkt dass
diese ampel wenn das der neue stil ist
jeder macht ständig seine vorschläge und
macht so seins und am ende werden keine
entscheidung getroffen dann ist das
einfach eine stange glaube noch nicht
kennt und man hat doch harry kreis
standen man hat es doch jetzt verstanden
das worauf es hinausläuft streit finde
ich allerdings ist gar nicht schlecht
dass in einer demokratie also wenn es in
eine koalition der button und streit und
konflikte gibt dann ist das doch
eigentlich nur ein ausschuss aus der
tatsache dass es verschiedene parteien
sind mit verschiedenen
grundüberzeugungen die da
zusammenarbeiten ich hätte mir oft
gewünscht in der zeit der großen
koalition das ist ein bisschen mehr
debattiert wird ich habe immer auf den
vereinigungsparteitag zwischen union spd
gemacht so in manchen phasen
und nein also
sie finden sich gut regiert hermannstein
das ist eine sehr schwierige frage also
ich würde sagen da warte ich noch so ein
bisschen ab aber die schwierigere
situation im vergleich zu der koalition
hat ja im moment eher die opposition
würde ich sagen denn was ist das denn
für eine aussichtslose lage
nach 16 jahren regierung man kann sich
nicht so recht absetzen von von frau
merkel das geht nicht ja wann
und welche neue welche neue richtung die
union endlich einschlägt und was für was
sie steht weiß ich immer noch nicht so
recht wissen sie ich bin ein versuch
wagen jetzt einfacher werden doch ein
neues tier sondern wir schauen jetzt ob
sie es nach der sein tier so gut regiert
also nur ein letztes jahr wäre wüsste
gerne ich hab's mir vor der letzten wahl
wirklich überlegt ich wüsste gerne ob es
irgendeinen grund gegeben hat oder geben
wird die union zu wählen ich bin jemand
der dafür ansprechbar wäre aber ich habe
es bei der letzten wahl einfach nicht
raus gekriegt was der grund sein könnte
könnte ich auch nachvollziehen jetzt
haben offensichtlich zu viele diesem
grund nicht gesehen weil anbieter
schlechtes ergebnis sind wir sind
abgewählt worden da gibt es nichts
drumherum zu reden er ist können wir
jetzt auch noch mal aufarbeiten aber ich
weiß jetzt nicht ob das wahlergebnis vom
letzten jahr das müssen wir aufarbeiten
da haben wir echt ein thema ich glaube
nicht dass das das hauptthema der
bürgerinnen bürger ist dem thema ist
gerade krieg in der ukraine die frage
wie deutschland sich da verhält oder
nicht verhält uns zu sagt und nicht hält
dieses thema ist energiepreise wie sie
die spritpreise was passiert beim gas
chris thema ist ob wir für unsere
industrie und für die arbeitsplätze
eigentlich noch das gas in den nächsten
monaten als energieform kriegen wie wir
es wie wir es brauchen das thema ist wie
die europäische union eigentlich
zusammen bleibt weil da auch schon die
ersten jahr wieder auftauchen in dieser
schwierigen zeit deswegen kann man sich
gerne den ganzen tag an den 16 jahren
abarbeiten ist alles okay ich stelle
mich jeder debatte ich weiß halt nur
nicht ob das so richtig die problemlage
trifft in der dieses land gerade ist
die entscheidung war auch die da war in
der runde zu wort kommen lassen vorgabe
wenn sie das zuhören wenn zwei politiker
sich so streiten in mir als bürgerin
becker ist immer ein gefühl von
beklemmung weil ich denke lasst uns
darüber die probleme reden und nicht
immer wer schuld hat habe also in denen
wir sind halt als bürger verunsichert
wir wissen nicht wo es hingehen und
streit ist ja schon gut aber muss er
wirklich in der öffentlichkeit
ausgetragen werden und wieso gibt es
nicht einfach lösung es sieht halt
wirklich aus zu jeder lösung bringt der
politiker ein problem und es müssen
einfach lösungen her und klar wie ich
schon vorher gesagt habe es ist nicht so
leicht da gibt es die einen die das
klima schützen wollen dann geht es
natürlich auch die wirtschaftliche lage
und es ist alles unter einen hut zu
bringen ist halt verdammt schwer und es
muss jetzt aber gemacht werden und diese
unbequemen fragen müssen jetzt
beantwortet werden und hoffentlich
zeitnah eine lösung hat ja christoph
meyer heute mitgebracht die
schuldenbremse ab 2023 die wünschen sich
ja auch viele bürger richtig also meine
these ist raus aus den schulden reinigen
die handlungsfähigkeit
schuldenbremse 20 23 wieder einhalten
wenn du als letzten drei jahre angucken
und dann haben wir eine sehr exzessive
schulden politik
in deutschland gesehen
teilweise bedingt durch die pandemie
situation alles richtig die frage aber
auch da muss man natürlich sagen sie
sind die mittel immer richtig ausgegeben
wurden aber wenn wir ehrlich sind haben
wir auch die ganzen letzten zehn jahre
die gute einnahmeentwicklung
situation des staates die ersparen ja
auch schon angesprochen hat nicht
genutzten das land zukunftsfähig zu
machen sollen das geld wurde verpasst
die einnahmen und wir müssen wieder
zurückkommen dauerhaft solide finanzen
zu haben wir bekämpfen mit der
einhaltung der schuldenbremse die
inflation weil wir den staat als
nachfrager ein stück weit zurücknehmen
schuldenbremsen einhalten solide
haushalte sind auch eine frage von
generationengerechtigkeit
und von handlungsfähigkeit insgesamt wir
müssen in diesem haushalt für das jahr
2023 das ist ja mittlerweile öffentlich
25 milliarden euro mehr für zinsen
ausgeben als im letzten jahr 25
milliarden euro mehr es sind fast das
doppelte des haushalts für das familie
und jugend ministerium also mit dem geld
hätte man sehr viel anderes machen
können als zinsen zu bezahlen und wir
müssen glaube ich grundsätzlich dazu
kommen das ist auch eine aufgabe für die
ampel ersparen sicherlich recht wenn die
ampel daten der anderen stelle auch in
der öffentlichkeit kritisiert hat wir
müssen wir dazu kommen dass
es zu guter politik nicht dazu gehört
immer nur mehr geld auszugeben sondern
am ende des tages muss man die
handlungsfähigkeit des staates stärken
das geht mit ganz ganz vielen maßnahmen
die auch kein geld kosten zum beispiel
handel stimulieren wir werden
zertifizieren das hat die große
koalition letzten jahren nicht geschafft
das lag an ihrem koalitionspartner wir
werden jetzt die lng terminals für
flüssiggas
beschleunigt bauen können es gibt ein
kabinettsbeschluss dass wir mit dieser
form von infrastruktur bau
beschleunigung auch andere
infrastrukturmaßnahmen beschleunigen
wenn das kostet alles kein geld und wenn
wir dahin kommen und nicht nur darauf
fokussieren wer als erstes am meisten
geld ausgibt dann wird das land das oft
geld sparen könnte man könnte die leute
zur verantwortung ziehen die halt um
diese steuergelder verschwenden
bekanntes tv-formate ich auch solche
sachen schon mal aufgedeckt haben dass
ein bett brücken gebaut werden die nicht
wohin führen und die leute diese halt so
was
durchbringen kreis nicht die müssen halt
auch mal das zur verantwortung gezogen
werden auch wenn es mit ihrem
persönlichen einkommen ist weil das geht
nicht wir müssen wirklich aufhören die
steuergelder zu verschwenden weil das
ist auch so dinge die uns halt dann
sauer machen eine ganz schwierige frage
an politiker ist ja immer die frage wo
soll denn gespart werden ja werden sich
etwas schmallippig also wenn man eine
schulden wenn man eine schuldenbremse
einheit aber nichtig sind stein ja
gerade mehrfach festgestellt hat sind
wir abgewählt worden
mehrheitlich nein die frage ist ja
richtig ist haben ja nicht zurück oder
sie wollen
formuliert hat nur frau
ja also die frage lautet wo soll gespart
werden denn ganz ohne sparen wird die
einhaltung der schuldenbremse nicht
funktionieren wenn wir corona die
bundeswehr und was sonst noch so alles
an deck das sind ja die zinsen haben sie
genannt das heißt es zum laufen
ausgabenposten auf jede menge und wenn
man da die nicht schulden machen will
dann muss man eben irgendwo sparen und
nachmachen lebenserfahrung ist das
doch immer ein ziemliches tabuthema
gewesen für regierende weil man sich
natürlich unbeliebt macht wenn man
irgendwo etwas kürzt da gehört natürlich
schneit dazu irgendwo was zu streichen
ich verstehe habe großes verständnis
dafür wenn sie da keine antwort parat
haben aber ich frage mich wie das dann
mit der schuldenbremse funktionieren
soll ohne irgendwo zu sparen müssen sie
erst mal ehrlich machen sozusagen die
hälfte des bundesetats geht mittlerweile
für soziales
darauf über den sozialen
transfers investiert das ist rente das
ist gesundheit
maßgeblich und natürlich müssen wir wenn
wir den haushalt konsolidieren wollen an
diese punkte ran das passiert momentan
im jahr 2023 relativ einfach weil viele
der korona maßnahmen auslaufen
zurückgenommen werden nicht weiter
verlängert werden aber natürlich muss
ihr nachfolger muss herr lauterbach in
der gesetzlichen krankenversicherung
etwas tun darüber reden wir ja in der
tat auch jetzt
werden die beiträge sollen erhöht werden
aber im winter auch ein system der gkv
mal hat es über 40 prozent soll ja ein
system der gkv müssen halt vom
gesundheitsminister auch entsprechende
vorschläge vorgelegt werden wie wir
nicht die lücke waren ja 14,8 milliarden
glaube ich die lauterbach aufgerufen hat
davon werden zwei milliarden euro mit
dem zuschuss aus dem staatshaushalt
belegt der rest muss anderswo her kommen
das heißt also wir müssen am ende des
tages sehr sehr klein telegramm das wird
im jahr 2023 noch nicht so schwer werden
aber im jahr 20 24 25 wenn es auch um
die priorisierung der vorhaben der ampel
geht dann werden wir ihn verteidigungs
diskussionen kommen sicherlich auch in
der öffentlichkeit da wird uns in der
öffentlichkeit auf
linien zu ersparen also wenn sie jetzt
die entscheidungsgewalt hätten heute ich
glaube wir sollten damit anfangen dass
sie im stellen körper sparen das fangen
wir jetzt auch an gerade 7000 neue
stellen weniger neue stellen geschaffen
als die große christus- und sie hat sich
gerade wollen sie sparen
was wir am anfang was jede
bundesregierung am anfang macht ist ein
stück weit eine priorisierung zu setzen
dass es vollkommen legitim das ist in
dem fall auch einiges anstellen die zum
beispiel
finanzverwaltung mehr genommen
ja das war ein ganz anderes thema aber
was wir mit diesem haushalt 20 23
anfangen ist dass wir in den ställen
körper dass der bundesrepublik eingehen
wollen dürfen wir ja wir werden eine
pauschale
stellenkürzung von 15 prozent ansetzen
das sind 3000 stellen dass wir erst mal
durchhalten die müssen dann die
einzelnen häuser so umsetzen und das
wollen wir in den nächsten jahren
fortsetzen und so können wir durch jeden
einzelnen etat durchgehen und können
sagen das ist das stichwort
wirkungsorientierte haushaltspolitik
auch dafür haben wir jetzt zwei stellen
zunächst erstmal geschafft und eine
finanziell stemmen dass wir uns an
gucken dass wir uns angucken was wir mit
einzelnen haushaltstiteln eigentlich die
wirkung nicht bewirken und wenn die
evolution dazu führt dass das geld nicht
sinnvoll ausgegeben wird dann wird man
darüber diskutieren müssen dass man
diese projekte diese maßnahmen
entsprechend streicht sie haben im
bildungsministerium haben wir sehr sehr
viele umschichtungen gemacht um die
bafög-reform also mehr geld für
studierende mehr geld auch im bereich
der forschungslandschaft das haben wir
aus dem etat 41 lang jeden einsparen ich
mir wünschen ja was meistens kurz sein
berlin sein dass die hat ja wohl doch
ein ja darf ich mit meinem guten ja
nochmal hier sitzen und wir gucken mal
will
nächstes jahr mit viel spaß und herr
meier wieder hier und nächste woche
dürfen sie sich aber auch freunde habe
ich auch sehr spannende gäste hier unter
anderem sarah wagenknecht gloria von
thurn und taxis und gaby hauptmann ich
freue mich schon sehr auf die drei damen
und jetzt schönen abend zu hause und
dann kam meine gäste das war lebens
[Musik]